let's go to the art of computer
programming in 1962 you set the table of
contents for this magnum opus right yeah
it was supposed to be a single book with
12 chapters now today what is it
57 years later you're in the middle of
volume 4 of 7 and in the middle of
volume 4 B is 4 B precisely can ask you
for an impossible task which is try to
summarize the book so far maybe by
giving a little examples so from the
sorting and the search in the
combinatorial algorithms if you were to
give a summary a quick elevator summary
yeah right what depending how many
floors are in the building yes the first
volume called fundamental algorithms
talks about something that you can't the
stuff you can't do without I guess that
you have to know the basic concepts of
what is a program now what is it what is
it algorithm and and and it also talks
about a low-level machine so you can
have some kind of an idea what's going
on and it has basic concepts of
input/output and subroutines the
induction induction writes mathematical
preliminaries so so the thing that makes
my book different from a lot of others
is that all that I try to not only
present the argument but I try to
analyze them and which means to
quantitatively I say not only does it
work but it works this fast ok and so I
need math for them and then there's the
standard way to structure data inside
and represent the information in the
computer so that's all volume 1 volume 2
talks
it's called semi numerical algorithms
and here we're here we're writing
programs but we're also dealing with
numbers the algorithms deal with with
with any kinds of objects but but
specific when there's
objects are numbers well then then we
have certain special paradigms that are
that apply to things that have 12
numbers and so there's there's what
there's like there's arithmetic on
numbers and and there's matrices full of
numbers there's random numbers and
there's power series full of numbers
there's different algebraic concepts
that have numbers in structured ways and
the Earthmen taking the way a computer
would think about arithmetic is the
floating point floating point arithmetic
high precision arithmetic not only
addition subtraction multiplication but
also comparison of numbers so then then
volume three talks about I like that one
sort insert sorting insert a lot sorting
right so so here you know we're not
getting necessarily with numbers because
you thought you saw it letters and other
objects and searching we're doing all
the time with Google nowadays but I mean
we have to find stuff so again
algorithms that that underlie all kinds
of applications like you know none of
these volumes is about a particular
application but the applications are
examples of of why people want to know
about sorting why people want to know
about random numbers so then volume 4
goes into combinatorial algún this is
where we have zillions of things to deal
with and we and here we keep finding
cases where one good idea can can make
something go more than a million times
faster and and and we're dealing with
problems that are probably never going
to be solved efficiently but that
doesn't mean we give up on them and and
and we have this chance to have good
ideas and and go much much faster on
them so so that's comets are algorithms
and those are the ones that are I music
shorting is most fun for you well well
like Zamora toriel algorithms are the
ones that I always that I always enjoyed
the most because that's when my skillet
programming had moles pay off and the
different difference between an obvious
algorithm that
think up first thing and a you know and
a good and it's just an interesting
subtle algorithm that not so obvious but
but run circles around the other one
that's that's where computer science 3d
comes that comes in and a lot of these
comets all methods were found first in
application start official intelligence
or cryptography and in my case I I just
liked him and it was associated more
with puzzles that you like the most in
the domain of graphs and graph theory
graphs are great because they're
terrific models of so many things in the
real world and you and you you throw
numbers on a graph you got a network and
so there you're right there you have but
many more things so but comet Oriole in
general is in any arrangement of objects
that that has some kind of a higher
structure non non random structure and
it's okay
it is possible to put something together
satisfying all these conditions like I
mentioned arrows a minute ago you know
is there a way to to put these numbers
on a bunch of boxes that that are
pointing to each other is that going to
be possible at all
that's volume four that's volume four
what is a sage of Hawaiian for a was
part one and and what happened was in
1962 when I started writing down a table
of contents it wasn't going to be a book
about computer programming in general it
was going to be a book about how to
write compilers and I was asked to write
a book explaining how to how to write a
compiler and at that time there were
only a few dozen people in the world who
had written compilers and I happen to be
one of them so and I also
had some experience writing for like the
campus newspaper and things like that so
so I said okay great
I'm the only person I know who who's
written a compiler but hasn't invented
any new techniques for writing compilers
and and all the other people I knew had
super ideas but I couldn't see that they
would be able to write a book that
wouldn't that would describe anybody
else's ideas with their own so I could
be the I could be the journalist and I
could explain what all these cool ideas
about compiler writing that were and and
and then I I started putting down well
yeah let me you need
have a chapter about data structures you
need to have some introductory material
but I want to talk about searching
because a compiler writer has to it has
to look up the variables in a symbol
table and find out you know which which
when you when you write the name of a
variable in one place is supposed to be
the same as the one you put somewhere
else so up now you need all these basic
techniques and I and I you know kind of
know some arithmetic itself so I so I
threw in these chapters and I threw in a
chapter on cognate orcs because that was
what I really enjoyed programming the
most but there weren't many algorithms
and known about combinatorial methods in
1962 so that was a kind of a short
chapter but it was sort of thrown
interest for fun and Chapter twelve was
going to be actual compilers applying
all the stuff in chapters 1 to 11 to
make compilers well ok so that was my
table of contents from 1962 and during
the 70s the whole field of combinatorics
what went through a huge explosion
people talk about it combinatorial
explosion and they usually mean by that
that the number of cases goes up you
know you change n to n plus 1 and all of
a sudden you your problem has gotten
more than ten times harder but there was
a explosion of ideas about calm networks
in the 70s and to the point that it like
take 1975 I
I bet you more than half of all the
journals of computer science we're about
combinatorial method
you